there are a few more powerful
illustrations of the migrant crisis on
Britain's doorstep than this French riot
police on the roads around the
Eurotunnel in cali they're struggling to
cope with hundreds of migrants so
desperate to hop aboard an unsuspecting
UK bound glory they're doing it in broad
daylight did you all come across
together from the Mediterranean yeah
this young Eritrean man who doesn't want
his facial over concerns for his family
back home told me despite the tight
security he's determined to make it to
the UK am I in in fact another load of
police officers going through now the
police are everywhere yeah everywhere as
you lay as you see there my notice us
there when we go there hey Kiki we go
there but you still try even even in the
daytime Emily I got time there is huge
frustration here and claims the
authorities are becoming increasingly
robust the Sudanese man says he was
beaten by the police and suffered
injuries to his hand and leg this is the
migrants main camp on the outskirts of
Carly the music helps break the tedium
for those far from home desperate to
find a new one in Britain people like
Ibrahim from Sudan who again doesn't
want his face shown he says friends of
his died trying to make it here tell us
about that journey how difficult was a
very small boat and the waves were so
high and
we lost our friends also they're trying
to make the best of it with what they've
got which is very little the more
enterprising have managed to open a
small shop a generator powers dozens of
phone chargers necessity means
everything is utilized here they've
chopped down some of the many trees in
the jungle to meet quarries at the
moment just a timber frame but
eventually this will be a charge for the
Eritrean community each evening hundreds
make their way to the only guaranteed
food source a soup kitchen run by local
charities for many it's their only meal
of the day by any measure this is a
wretched existence and the crisis here
is worse now than it's been for many
years mark white sky news in cali